your doctor will perform a dilation and
curettage to remove
tissue from inside the uterus the uterus
is a muscular reproductive organ in the
lower abdomen the lower part of the
uterus called the cervix connects the
vagina to the
uterus  a
diagnostic test may be performed to investigate the cause of
the following conditions
abnormal or heavy bleeding severe menstrual pain
difficulty getting pregnant
or abnormal cells found on a
pap smear
a therapeutic test may be performed to treat certain
uterine conditions such as
excessive bleeding  from remnants of the placenta
after birth polyps in
the cervix and uterine polyps
fibroid tumors which are
benign growths formed in the uterine wall and
incomplete miscarriage or
induced abortion in which parts of the
embryo or fetus or associated tissues
remain in  the uterus it
is possible that the doctor p  refer to
start the dilation process the day
before the procedure if so
the doctor will place a thin bar
called a laminaria in the cervix or
a medication to soften the cervix
the laminaria slowly expands by
absorbing fluid from the
cervix which causes  your cervix
opens
during the procedure you
will lie on your back with your
legs in stirrups as you
would for a normal pelvic exam
receive local or general anesthesia
your doctor will insert a speculum into your
vagina to widen the vaginal canal so you
can see  the cervix
during dilation the doctor will
insert a series of smooth rods into the
opening of the cervix each rod
will be repositioned with a slightly
thicker rod so that the opening of
the cervix slowly widens or dilates
so that the inside can be accessed
of the uterus
once the cervix has
expanded to about 6 to 9 millimeters
Usually the doctor may perform
a hysterectomy a procedure in
which a small light and
camera are used to examine the inside of the
uterus for abnormal areas then
the doctor will perform curettage which is the
surgical removal of part or
all of the  lining of the uterus called the
endometrium
during curettage a
surgical tool called a tray will be inserted
to remove the tissue by scraping or
suctioning
if you are undergoing a
diagnostic test the doctor will remove only
a small sample of the endometrium and
send it to a laboratory for evaluation
to check for different conditions if you
are undergoing therapeutic
ats the doctor will remove the entire contents
of your uterus to treat a
confirmed uterine condition after the
procedure you will be monitored in a
recovery room for a few hours
before going home to
prevent a  infection do not have
sex or use tampons
for about two weeks or
until your doctor tells you it is
safe to do so because your uterus will
need to build a new
wall your next menstrual period may
not occur regularly